what advice would you give to young
folks
today about career about life whether
they want to be
writers lawyers
scientists musicians and artists
whatever the heck they want to be how
can they live a life they can be proud
of okay here's what i think
um
you should absolutely
do that thing that you're dying to do
but
you should always have a plan b
um and like a backup plan and a way of
earning a living no matter what happens
because that's funny i feel like people
we we have this narrative in our culture
of like the glamorous thing is to
you know
figure out the thing you love and then
risk everything yeah to achieve that
but
first of all a lot of people aren't
comfortable with that level of risk and
second when you're living with that
level of risk
that's a cognitive load too and so you
don't have the full emotion and heart to
be able to focus on the thing that you
actually really love because you're like
stressed out about it so i'd say like
get the backup plan in place and then do
the thing
my advice would be the opposite huh okay
i'm living like the romantic well
i think the best the the the truth is
be
aware of the cost
not having a plan b has so do it
deliberately if you don't
but i you know i'm with bukowski and
find what you love and let it kill you
i think
now you have to actually know your
personality i know if i have a plan b
i will not try as hard on plan a
and i would likely
take plan b
because if if plan a is is the risky
thing
i just work way much better when uh in
the state of desperation so with my back
against the wall and you have to know
that about yourself i think that has to
do with so i think we can refine it to
say you actually have to really know
yourself and how you respond to
different kinds of risks
like i i would not do well in that kind
of situation i'd be like up at two in
the morning worrying about it yeah
whereas
if i have some like it doesn't have to
be paying the rent in some grand way but
i've if there's some basic way of paying
the rent then my heart's free to do the
thing i really love that's hilarious i
for me the only way i'm free is
um when i don't know how i'm gonna be
there right
huh
yeah because that's because otherwise
i'll
find a way to pay the rent that's not at
all a source of deep fulfillment for me
so i see so it's like if you don't have
like the
what's the expression i don't know
something like the dog at your back yeah
you know the deadline then you won't
actually do it i create real or
artificial deadlines
anxiety and so on so
yeah
yeah so so really the advice is know
your triggers um but yeah but but we're
still saying that the same basic thing
of like do the thing you really love
but just set up the strategize the rest
of your properly to your personality
exactly exactly
uh what do you think is the meaning of
life
the meaning of this whole thing
um probably has something to do with
whatever we feel when we listen to a sad
song
yeah i
because two things come simultaneously
to my mind when you ask that question
and i've been asking it since i was four
i remember the first time i did
um
the question is more important than the
answer probably yeah just keep asking
i don't know the first one is beauty and
i don't know why beauty is so important
but i just know that it is impossible to
define perhaps
is it definable um
other than you know it when you see it
i don't know i mean just
has to do with that line
yeah you feel something when you just
see it or you hear it yeah you just see
it and it's like
like some
it's
whatever can deliver you to that mode of
transcendence where you're no longer
purely in your own self and
you're in something higher
and
when you're in those states of mind
you know it because
you have the temporary sensation that
that you could die at that moment that
the people you love could die and it
will all be okay because there's
something else
so that's my first answer and then my
second answer is um
the need to relieve psychic pain
like other people's psychic pain i don't
know why that's just that's just like an
impulse that i have psychic pain is more
like like suffering in any form
what it was yeah but i mean
what is their particular yeah just make
making the world
better and
less pain
less pain to go around in general um
hence you're just sort of optimistic
desire and longing for a world without
sort of destruction
without
malevolent destruction
yeah a world where that wouldn't be
necessary yeah exactly exactly but yeah
like i i so i had this moment
it wasn't so long ago i was doing some
interview and somebody asked me like
what are you longing for right now
and
my answer at that moment was like
you know what i'm actually at this
moment in life where i'm not longing for
anything i'm at this particular way
station where everything
is the way i want it to be
and
of course the minute you say something
like that
you know you're going to be proven wrong
because like an hour later i get
a letter from
a reader who i've been in touch with
over the years and he was telling me
about like a psychic struggle that he's
going through and
and i just felt like oh my gosh if there
were anything i could do to make it that
his life wouldn't have been such that he
would be in this position in the first
place like his struggles had to do with
a long life history
so i don't know why i feel that it's
funny but i do
those moments when you're just at peace
there's nothing else you want
feel like that's like a temporary repose
like a pause exactly
you could you bet your ass
a desire follows that at some point but
you get to enjoy those little moments
yeah
when i said even when he asked me and i
answered that way i said this is a way
station like i knew it was temporary but
i didn't realize it would be disrupted
like an hour later
and uh sort of to give you pushback
to your
to your statement about the the
possibility of uh
because of beauty
and basically alleviating suffering
there's a quote i really like from
hunter s thompson that pushes back
against that which is for every moment
of triumph for every instance of beauty
many souls must be trampled
but that's a very hunter s thompson
and you know how yeah
he's not the greatest philosopher of all
times but he's certainly a
a beautiful a chaotic human being well
that's true and i will tell you that my
nickname for my husband is gonzo kind of
because of him you know he invented that
form of gonzo journalism where like the
the writer is totally
in the story
and my husband like that's his
personality he's like in everything that
he does he's really in it he's really
present he just lives that way so
well then so his name is ken but i call
him gonzo like 90 of the time
well then that's a beautiful way to end
this season this is uh thank you for
your work thank you for being who you
are thanking you for initially at least
making me feel okay about being an
introvert and educating and making the
rest of us feel great about being
introverts it's like half the world or
whatever the heck it is it's a lot of
people
thank you for being you
thank you for talking today this is
awesome this is fun thank you so much it
was so great to talk to you and i think
it was the
what i said to you when we first got
connected is thank you for your way of
being in the world i
really really love it
you